et on en parle avec olivier d'organes ce
bonjour vous êtes avocat au cabinet à
seurre vous êtes surtout expert en
sanctions économiques on vient
d'entendre bruno le maire nous allons
provoquer l'effondrement de l'économie
l'économie russe parmi la série de
mesures annoncées quels sont selon vous
à celles qui sont le plus efficaces
celles qui seront les plus efficaces
très clairement ce sont les sanctions
qui visent le système financier russe
notamment les banques qui ont été pour
certaines places et soulisse déjà fait
d'avoir également les mesures qui ont
été annoncées en fin d'après-midi et
précise entre la première contre la
banque centrale de russie convocation à
empêcher la banque centrale de russie
d'utiliser les réserves qu'elle a
accumulées ces dernières dernières
années pour porter secours aux
entreprises russes qui vont commencer à
ressentir l'effet des sanctions
ajustements sur les faits de ces
sanctions comment l'économie à elle peut
résister
l'économie peut résister de par la
préparation qui a été entreprise par la
russie depuis le rejet net l'enrichît
accumule un nombre très important de
réserves notamment elle a également
restructurer profondément sa tête sa
dette publique et fait partie des débats
publics les plus basses de des grandes
des grandes puissances économiques est
par ailleurs la russie peut aspirer même
si c'est un petit peu plus ambigu
aujourd'hui que ça ne m'était ya une
semaine un éventuel soutien de la part
de la chine mais en tout cas les
sanctions qui ont été adoptés sont d'une
telle violence est tellement inédite
dans leur histoire que l économie on est
sûr d'avoir bien du mal à supporter l
ses sanctions sur le long cours on a
compris le nerf de la guerre entre
guillemets c'est l'énergie sega c'est le
pétrole dont la russie est très riche
des géants des hydrocarbures comme celle
par exemple bp ou encore total energy se
désengage justement de ce marché russe
quel va être l'impact pour les russes et
l'impact aussi pour nous européens
alors l'impact pour les européens c'est
est ce qu'il ya c'est ce qui a justifié
en tout cas une forme de réserve de la
parole de l'union européenne sur les
sanctions sur ce secteur on est encore
en plein coeur de l'hiver on est encore
dépendants très fortement alors
peut-être pas forcément la france mais
nos voisins européens sont très
dépendants du gaz russe notamment
l'allemagne l'italie donc on n'a pas
souhaité
aujourd'hui encore imposé de sanctions
spécifiques sur ces produits mais les
investissements successifs de shell et 2
et 2 et de bp en russie et la position
de non nouvel investissement de la part
de total energy vont apporter de grandes
difficultés techniques elle a à la
russie pour autant aujourd'hui encore la
russie a annoncé la signature d'un
partenariat important entre gazprom et
la chine et donc il est aussi fort à
parier que le marché chinois et certains
marchés qui permettent à la russie de
continuer à exporter une partie de son
gaz alors il va y avoir un impact sur de
ses sanctions sur les économies
européennes notamment sur le prix de
l'essence le prix de gaz on parle de
décence qui déjà un plus haut depuis
depuis des années
oui très clairement après l'augmentation
des prix de l'énergie elle et elle est
conjoncturelle ne datent pas de cette
crise les prix de l'énergie avaient
atteint des sommets déjà bien avant
l'incursion militaire russe sur le
territoire ukrainien par ailleurs
l'augmentation à l'inflation des prix en
matière et gazière elle est aussi liée
au contexte géopolitique
tendu inédit et donc de fait très
clairement ce sont ces chèques ce cumul
de facteurs qui contribuent aujourd'hui
avoir une inflation des prix et donc
l'inflation des prix pour le
consommateur
que peut faire concrètement le kremlin
contre l'union européenne et que contre
tous est cesser toutes ces sanctions qui
sont en train d'être prises contre
moscou
très concrètement le kremlin peut
espérer capitaliser sur les nombreux
investissements étrangers directs
français européens sur le territoire
russe une des possibilités qui
s'offriront aux gamins et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'a annoncé vladimir
poutine aussi récemment que vendredi
dernier serait de prendre des
contre-mesures qui viendrait de viser
des actifs financiers français et
étrangers sur le territoire russe on
peut éventuellement penser dans un
scénario maximaliste à des
nationalisations par exemple des
participations de grands groupes
français dans des dents des
joint-ventures ou d'autres partenariats
signés avec des entreprises russes qui
serait relativement à désastreux
d'emprunt de l'économie que les clés les
empereurs les investissements directs
français en russie représente plusieurs
dizaines de milliards d'euros boris
johnson parle et olaf scholz aussi le
championnat allemand parle de nouveau
train de sanctions très prochainement
comment sanctionner encore plus
la dîmière poutine alors il ya deux
dernières mesures de sanctions qui n'ont
pas été prises la première ce sont des
sanctions qui ont trait aux fectivement
secteur gazier vous disiez tout à
l'heure le secteur gazier les imports ne
sont toujours pas interdit au niveau
européen on pourrait envisager notamment
au fur et à mesure de la sortie de
l'hiver des sanctions sur ce secteur qui
viendraient considérablement appauvrir
la russie qui dépend très fortement de
ses exports de de gaz et de pétrole ça
c'est la première salle et de sanction
et la 2e service ce serait de
complètement détruites et l'économie
risque on sait qu'aujourd'hui les
premières banques russes qu'ils vont
être sortis de swift dont être vont être
annoncées mais on pourrait envisager de
faire rentrer un blocus total de 2,2
swift et interdira tout le système
bancaire russe d'avoir accès à ses
services de messagerie une dernière
question en comparaison des sanctions
contre la corée du nord et notamment
l'iran comment on peut évaluer ses
sanctions contre la russie c'est du même
niveau
elles sont par rapport à ce qu'ils les
sanctions existantes contre l'iran la
corée du nord elles sont un petit peu
moins complexe en tout cas - transverses
sont en activité et par contre il faut
pas sous-estimer le fait que la russie
est un partenaire commercial de premier
plan dans nombre de démocraties
occidentales et donc elles sont
paradoxalement même si elles sont
peut-être moins largement étendue que
les sanctions contre l'iran et la corée
du nord elles sont peut-être elles ont
des effets potentiellement beaucoup plus
grand sur l'économie mondiale et sur
l'économie russe parce que la russie est
un pays une puissance économique de
premier plan et que les sanctions dont
vous feriez dont vous parlez sont des
sanctions qui ont été prononcées à
l'encontre de pays qui avaient des
économie moins dépendante de l'occident
et du dos la non merci beaucoup olivier
d'organes c'est d'avoir été en direct
sur france 5 elle rappelle vous êtes
avocat et expert en sanctions
économiques